there is a massive disruption going on
right now just in 2016
70 percent of Americans watch cable TV
just in 2016 today's at 40 all right
from 70 to 40 today things have changed
where a guy named Elon Muska Twitter Fox
news's viewership has dropped nearly 60
percent since Tucker left and not just
his show every show Hannity shows took a
hit morning shows taking hit everybody's
there taking a hit we know what's going
on with CNN CNN's biggest hit that they
had was the CNN town hall with Trump
then you see what's going on with Rumble
Rumble Chris doing a great job Chris and
I spoke here today yeah he's doing a
great job he just brought David sacks on
the board and that's a that's a big deal
my thought is long-term eventually I
think Twitter May uh making a decision
to do something with Rumble who knows if
that's gonna happen or not I've been
saying this on the podcast for the last
few weeks but I think there's a major
major competition going on right now in
the media space